[Musique]
hop je rêvais d'être au monde i'm outta
love en fait je me crée une petite fille
m'aurait étonné par la première fin il a
compris que vous ne serez jamais comme
les autres que je ne te donnerai jamais
record alors le prix j'ai cherché toutes
les solutions possibles et imaginables
pour atteindre mais atteint alors
nakhonay rhmani et je suis devenue
avocate
parce qu'on va dire que c'était
impossible que ce métier n'était pas
peur je suis devenue avocate
parce que je reconnais ce sentiment
d'être différent
ce sentiment d'un l'outil surtout preuve
'triple a' peuvent dormir sur lui requis
repères
pourquoi et puis je suis parti à la
recherche d'un autre rêve réaliste sur
les retrouver être tam heureux et
épanoui on accepte pleinement mardi
table et donc accepter pleinement ma
différence mais je suis devenue la femme
que vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est une
femme libre et privés
de paso mais surtout le pam qu'il
n'abandonne jamais et je suis là ce soir
parce que nous y sommes tous des rêves
de notre vie professionnelle de notre
revenu personnel une mission puces pour
frotter à des mourres des barrières des
difficultés tous fous là ce soir pour
partager deux clés pour vous non plus ne
jamais abandonner
la première clé si la persévérance le 2
novembre 2006 nos charges à table par
valider mon diplôme d'avocat nos plus
grands cabinets anglo ciation et
j'obtiens un entretien bien sûr vous ne
pas mentionner médicale sur le fil à
l'entretien j'explique ma surdité
tu sais pas bien elles ne peuvent avoir
toutes nos chances l'autre tiers se
termine nous recommencer à mettre nos
moutons
il a n'a daigné me rattrape mais maudit
maintenant je ne comprends pas comment
une personne comme vue peut prétendre
exercer la profession d'avocat est là
pour la deuxième fois
mon rêve est tout bête
les bus
je suis sûr que vous y avez déjà vécu
eux mêmes plats une situation aussi
difficile que je baptise de notre
serveur a fort mal à notre petit moi
intérieur celui qui a peur
notre petite démo à taire leur travail
et se donnent à coeur joie n'en veut ni
ne me souvenais pas un métier pour toi
retourne ailleurs deux autres fouilles
un loup nous laisser nous empêcher de
réaliser le rêve certainement pas pour
être persévérant il peut trois fonds la
première un but clair on oubliait type
très très clair vous devez savoir
exactement vilaine
je voulais être avocate pour connaître
le droit de ne plus mener ses pairs par
les personnes que vous disiez elle
savait tout no comment la deuxième chose
au bout de bras
ces adhésions poussins vous devez
absolument vous devez absolument aller
jusqu'au bout parce que le reboot 1 est
très important port of et hommes ne pas
habituer nous ne comprenais pas pourquoi
il y avait des barrières contre les
autres n'avaient pas pourquoi en
accessibilité est aussi difficile à
avoir de le pays des droits de l'homme
liberté égalité fraternité
la troisième chose que vous devez avoir
c'est une sortie de zone europe à settat
vous devez absolument pu mettre en
oeuvre pour réaliser votre rêve surtout
des foules que vous n'avez jamais prêté
ou de bertone a échoué pour trouver la
bonne stratégie est réussi ou drapées
mon cabinet d'avocats quand tu m'as dit
cette petite taille pas très fiable
habituelle de ce genre de situation je
prenais ne travaille jamais shot à
pleine figure
j'appelle les médecins arrivent elles ne
nous disait rien et pour la première
fois je peux pas tu perds comme par
hasard genou le job
payez-vous
[Musique]
et payer 3000 euros par ma tombe à l'eau
non mais ils refusent parce que vous ne
mettez pas se retirer petit et donc
c'est ça la persévérance c'est ne
surtout pas abandonner dans les moments
difficiles parce qu'au sénat quand vous
faites la différence
si jamais vous abandonner c'est
exactement comme si vous passiez de
rogner à tous les efforts que vous
habitez 80 alors que c'est vraiment ça
que vous voulez je vous ai qui
persévèrent pour réussir tête d'une
nouvelle solution sur découvre de
nouvelles passes les petits tapis trop
coûteuse et ça c'est la deuxième recrue
ou de tagab enfin moody's et de riz ni
ne parlera jamais tu n'apprendra jamais
amené à écrire tu n'auras jamais de
battre me renvoyer des médias un négatif
mes professeurs le médecin ne personnes
qui ne me connaissent pas ou modifiées
par exemple pour tout diplôme d'avocat
tu devrais prendre une petite carte
familiale de province une arrière votre
la province mais ce sera plus facile
pour toi mais moi je voulais rester à
paris je voulais avoir la même dire que
les autres le même rémy ambitieux le
bayer bien comment mes amis
et comment guybet commun un passé et je
ne me sentais pas tellement différente
la perte causse à mes capacités mais toi
mais tous dehors de la salle que vous
avez déjà où le sentiment pour vous mais
la tête fut le cas où il y avait déjà un
certain professeur que vous apportez
pour le devenir grave et qu'il y avait
déjà le sentiment religieux estimé à 9 u
laisser les autres décider de votre dit
à votre place
et bien c'est ça notre club ce soit via
a baissé malgré de beaux frères sait
écouter cette petite voire une mise à nu
qui nous dit il
concrètement comment pouvons nous avons
2 20 la première celle que nous avons
vue du thabor notre petite démo
intérieur c'est tout petit mois il a
peur qui nous juge qui nous critiquent
dernier ne passe pas comme ça à tous pas
trop peur ni ne peut passer en mode ie7
bana c'est notre pire ennemi
si tu ne bat ils nous trouvent butiner
les prix possibles et imaginables pour
ne pas payer en actions
vous n'êtes pas le diplôme j'avais dit
up
on ne voudra de moi je suis trop jeune
je suis trop vieux
vous n'êtes pas le buzz mais c'est à 17h
et puis vous avez une deuxième fois
c'était pas c'est une eva ne peut que de
bien qui est très discrète
abu dis mais pourquoi pas et si on
essayait cette voie là c'est la voix de
votre tasse hier de vie de votre peur de
vous tromper
et cette balade des ciels il vous
connaît le nul effet pourquoi vous êtes
vraiment à part alors comment reprise
est amorcée de 20 et bien c'est très
simple quand vous n'êtes pas un choix
mais recruter toujours l'envoi de votre
pain certes il dit j'ai envie et s'y
essayer et puis pas payé en actions
utilisez votre mot talent pour élaborer
les 38 s il essayait cas et si vous
prenez cette voie et si on demandait à
telle personne ne reproche un choix
c'est cette certitude absolue
comme il ya des arrivées peu importe les
obstacles rencontrés ou ne savent pas
forcément comment n'est pas un royaume
il ya beau y arriver mais vous le savez
c'est notre dj mag a pris en otage puis
c'est facile avoue finaliser ce n'est
pas aussi difficile qu'on ne veut pas
c'est parce que ou non et à coup de
chaud et où difficile le port saïd en
vue de partager un exemple de jackman
qui est le fondateur d'alibaba jack ma a
échoué trois fins un équivalent du bac
oshie a été refoulée 10 voix pour plus
d'un trade abad a été une trentaine de
bêtes
regardez l'opiiec notre truc vous pensez
que depuis cnet les choses ont beaucoup
changé
brad 90% des personnes qui se loge dans
la première can kiss la run off sur les
dix portions voeux jusqu'au bout de
lorraine
c'est sa brève réaliste c'est un rêve
qu'on aura rien
et maintenant si vous souhaitez vous
aussi partie de ce divorce a rappelé guy
sié de créer soyez persévérant croyons
et maintenant que vous connaissez mes
secrets mais secret d'une panne
il n'abandonne jamais sortez but aussi
de train de retard autorisé but à rêver
gras foncé vers le meilleur d'eux mêmes
vous êtes les seuls à pouvoir construire
la nuit de brèves passer à l'action et
surtout de néma de bonnes nouvelles
[Applaudissements]